In the previous video we
identified clusters, or tissue
substances, in a
healthy brain image.
It would be really
helpful if we can
use these clusters to
automatically detect
tumors in MRI images
of sick patients.
The tumor.csv file corresponds
to an MRI brain image
of a patient with
oligodendroglioma,
a tumor that commonly occurs
in the front lobe of the brain.
Since brain biopsy is the
only definite diagnosis
of this tumor, MRI guidance is
key in determining its location
and geometry.
Now, make sure that
the tumor.csv file
is in your current directory.
Let's go to the console,
and clear it, and then
read the data, and
save it to a data frame
that we're going to call tumor,
and use the read.csv function,
which takes as an input
the tumor dataset,
and make sure to turn off
the header using header
equals FALSE.
And let's quickly
create our tumorMatrix,
using the as.matrix
function over the tumor data
frame, and the tumorVector,
using the as.vector
function over the tumorMatrix.
Now, we will not run the
k-means algorithm again
on the tumor vector.
Instead, we will apply the
k-means clustering results
that we found using
the healthy brain
image on the tumor vector.
In other words, we
treat the healthy vector
as training set and the tumor
vector as a testing set.
To do this, we first
need to install
a new package that
is called flexclust.
So let us type
install.packages("flexclus").
And then the first
thing R will ask
us is to set the
region that is closest
to our geographical location.
And after that, press
OK, and the installation
shouldn't take more than
two seconds to complete.
OK.
Now that the package
is installed,
let us load it by typing
library(flexclust).
The flexclust package contains
the object class KCCA,
which stands for K-Centroids
Cluster Analysis.
We need to convert the
information from the clustering
algorithm to an object
of the class KCCA.
And this conversion
is needed before we
can use the predict function
on the test set tumorVector.
So calling our new
variable KMC.kcca
and then using the
as.kcca function, which
takes as a first input the
original KMC variable that
stored all the information
from the k-means clustering
function, and the second input
is the data that we clustered.
And in this case,
it's the training set,
which is the healthyVector.
And now, be aware that
this data conversion
will take some time to run.
Now that R finally finished
creating the object KMC.kcca,
we can cluster the
pixels in the tumorVector
using the predict function.
Let us call the cluster
vector tumorClusters =
predict(KMC.kcca,
newdata=tumorVector).
And now, the
tumorClusters is a vector
that assigns a value 1 through
5 to each of the intensity
values in the
tumorVector, as predicted
by the k-means algorithm.
To output the segmented
image, we first
need to convert the tumor
clusters to a matrix.
So let's use the
dimension function,
and then the input is
simply tumorClusters,
and then using the c
function with the first input
as the number of rows
in the tumorMatrix
and the second
input as the number
of columns in the tumorMatrix.
And now, we can
visualize the clusters
by using the image function with
the input tumorClusters matrix,
and make sure to set
the axes to FALSE,
and let's use again these
fancy rainbow colors, here.
So col=rainbow(k).
Again, k is equal to 5.
Alright.
Let's navigate to
the graphics window,
now, to see if we
can detect the tumor.
Oh, and yes, we do!
It is this abnormal
substance here
that is highlighted
in blue that was not
present in the
healthy MRI image.
So we were successfully able
to identify, more or less,
the geometry of the
malignant structure.
We see that we did a good job
capturing the major tissue
substances of the brain.
The grey matter is highlighted
in purple and the white matter
in yellow.
For the sick patient, the
substance highlighted in blue
is the oligodendroglioma tumor.
Notice that we do not see
substantial blue regions
in the healthy
brain image, apart
from the region around the eyes.
Actually, looking
at the eyes regions,
we notice that the two images
were not taken precisely
at the same section
of the brain.
This might explain
some differences
in shapes between
the two images.
Let's see how the images
look like originally.
We see that the tumor region
has a lighter color intensity,
which is very similar to
the region around the eyes
in the healthy brain image.
This might explain highlighting
this region in blue.
Of course, we cannot claim
that we did a wonderful job
obtaining the exact geometries
of all the tissue substances,
but we are definitely
on the right track.
In fact, to do so, we need to
use more advanced algorithms
and fine-tune our
clustering technique.
MRI image segmentation is an
ongoing field of research.
While k-means clustering
is a good starting point,
more advanced
techniques have been
proposed in the literature, such
as the modified fuzzy k-means
clustering method.
Also, if you are
interested, R has
packages that are specialized
for analyzing medical images.
Now, if we had MRI
axial images taken
at different sections
of the brain,
we could segment each image
and capture the geometries
of the substances
at different levels.
Then, by interpolating
between the segmented images,
we can estimate
the missing slices,
and we can then obtain
a 3D reconstruction
of the anatomy of the brain
from 2D MRI cross-sections.
In fact, 3D reconstruction
is particularly
important in the medical
field for diagnosis,
surgical planning, and
biological research purposes.
I hope that this
recitation gave you
a flavor of this fascinating
field of image segmentation.
In our next video, we will
review all the analytics tools
we have covered so
far in this class
and discuss their
uses, pros, and cons.